qui prend cette année une signification
toute particulière puisque l'on revient
à une édition normale de la
commémoration sans restriction sanitaire
et avec bien sûr le retour du défilé des
vétérans alors ces images elles vous
parviennent en direct de la Place de la
Confédération à Ottawa ou s'élève le
monument commémoratif de guerre du
Canada vous voyez ces anciens
combattants qui se préparent et qui se
dirigent en fait vers le monument il
fait assez doux pour un 11 novembre
c'est rare et cette cérémonie c'est une
occasion de s'arrêter de penser à ceux
qui ont servi notre pays
117.000 Canadiens ont donné leur vie au
cours des différentes guerres pensez
aussi à ceux qui servent encore et tout
de suite je joins sur le terrain mon
collègue Daniel Thibault animateur des
coulisses du pouvoir Daniel bonjour
alors parlez-nous de cette atmosphère
aujourd'hui pour ce sans quatrième
anniversaire déjà
donc voilà d'abord vous l'évoquez
température particulièrement clémente
de degrés peut-être un peu plus le
maximum aujourd'hui prévu à Ottawa c'est
17 on est on a vu des années ici où on
était couvert de neige le 11 novembre et
où le mercure était dans les environs
environnés zéro degré alors aujourd'hui
une journée beaucoup plus douce pour les
gens qui sont ici ayant beaucoup
beaucoup de monde évidemment il y a plus
de monde cette année qu'on en a vu dans
les deux dernières années pour une
raison évidente la pandémie depuis deux
ans considérablement limité la capacité
de tenir cette cérémonie en plein
centre-ville l'année dernière on avait
demandé aux gens de rester à la maison
et de regarder la cérémonie à la
télévision pour éviter de se retrouver
avec de grands rassemblements qui
auraient pu devenir des foyers de
propagation de la covid-19 l'année
précédente alors qu'on commençait en
entrant dans la pandémie et en raison de
l'âge vétérans on avait ramené la
cérémonie à sa plus simple expression et
en avait évité justement le défilé des
vétérans pour s'assurer justement de pas
mettre leur ne pas mettre leur vie en
danger alors bon cette année du public
beaucoup de publics des membres du corps
militaire du corps diplomatique des
représentants du gouvernement Mary
Simmons seraient ici la gouverneur
général c'est sa seconde de cérémonie du
jour du Souvenir Justin Trudeau n'y sera
pas que Trudeau est en route vers l'Asie
pour un voyage d'une dizaine de jours
participer une série de sommets
internationaux il était de il est arrêté
en Alaska ce matin où il a entre autres
salué l'équipage militaire de son
appareil façon pour lui de souligner le
moment souligner jour du Souvenir c'est
le handsmaker le ministre des Anciens
combattants qui représentera le
gouvernement canadien avec à ses côtés
ce qui est Grégoire Trudeau qui sera ici
également
très bien alors Daniel on vous retrouve
tout au long de cette émission merci à
plus tard
à tout de suite
et pendant qu'on voit ses anciens
combattants donc ils se dirigent vers le
monument commémoratif de guerre et
ensuite bien sûr ils pourront défiler
après la cérémonie officielle alors je
vous présente tout de suite nos invités
sur le plateau vous les connaissez
Marie-Ève Vaillancourt donc qui est
directrice des expositions au Centre
Juno Beach en France et le
lieutenant-colonel à la retraite Rémy
Landry bonjour à vous deux merci d'être
avec nous ce matin bonjour
alors cette cérémonie officielle elle va
débuter à 11h bien sûr à la 11e heure du
11e jour du 11e mois ça veut souligner
l'armistice donc la fin de la Première
Guerre mondiale il y aura deux minutes
de silence pourquoi sur un plan
peut-être plus personnel pour commencer
c'est important pour vous de se souvenir
de s'arrêter en cette journée je vais
commencer avec vous monsieur l'anglais
du sacrifice de tous ces gens-là qui ont
fait du Canada ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
et puis personnellement comme militaire
c'est ça c'est le fait l'époque le
moment où on se rappelle de la caméra de
riz on se rappelle de ceux qui nous ont
quittés alors un service soit avec les
Nations Unies avec le temps ou en
Afghanistan en Corée en deuxième guerre
mondiale pour quelques qui restent
encore avec nous c'est de leur rendre
hommage de se souvenir de tous ces
gens-là qui ont pas eu la chance comme
ceux qui restent de pouvoir vivre avec
leur famille donc pour moi c'est c'est
un moment précieux toujours important
toujours important la vente de
coquelicots aussi c'est important le
fait de perpétuer ce souvenir là puisse
s'assurer que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
vont continuer de se rappeler parce que
les années passent bien sûr donc c'est
important de de rappeler aux jeunes ce
qui s'est passé oui ben on remarque avec
le défilé des vétérans tout de suite
déjà qu'il y a une grande transition qui
s'opère cette année on le voit peu de
vétérans de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et on voit cette nouvelle diversité dans
l'usage libérez bleu des plus moderne
plus jeune donc si on veut l'image
exactement c'est une transition
importante et on est en crise souvent
dans les vétérans de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale pour le jour de souvenirs mais
maintenant il faut se tourner vers le
présent futur et
finalement c'est vétérans qui remplacent
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale ouais on
en voit on envoie en ce moment même donc
des vétérans qui sont plus jeunes on
pourrait peut-être parler de ces de ces
nouveaux vétérans donc qui qui se
sentent comme les anciens est-ce que ou
bien est-ce qu'ils ont l'impression
parfois peut-être que ils ont moins
d'aura peut-être que ceux qui ont fait
toutes ces grandes guerres peut-être
mais définitivement avoir été au service
de et puis c'est ça qui est important
c'est que ces gens-là ont décidé d'être
au service du pays et puis de faire ce
que le pays leur demande dans les
intérêts du pays donc pour moi oui une
différence entre avoir combattu la
deuxième guerre mondiale qui s'est
déroulée sur cinq ans mais je regarde
des camarades qui ont fait l'Afghanistan
un tour du Tour
qui a duré 12 ans donc pour moi ces
gens-là ont autant de valeur que ceux
qui nous ont quittés lors de la première
guerre ou la deuxième guerre le contexte
était complètement différent et puis
avec ce qui se passe en Ukraine
aujourd'hui ben peut-être que il y aura
peut-être un après Ukraine à suivre
alors parce qu'on a en ce moment des
soldats qui forment les Ukrainiens donc
en Estonie notamment en Grande-Bretagne
en Pologne et puis on sait que depuis le
début du conflit en Ukraine on a
augmenté énormément notre présence
canadienne en Europe de façon
jeunes significatif de dissuasion face
parce que évidemment ce conflit en
Ukraine nous rappelle bien sûr
les guerres parce que on est ici on a
été épargné mais en Europe il y a cette
guerre qui est vraiment en Europe quoi
oui certainement la guerre en Ukraine
est au port de l'Europe et pour les
Européens ça rappelle
1938-1939 en ce moment c'est des
conditions assez extrêmes de se rappeler
que 80 ans plus tard les choses
recommencent au même point
l'intensité aussi de voir tous ces
réfugiés là moi lorsque j'ai vu les
premiers réfugiés qui fuyaient l'Ukraine
ça m'a permis un plus petit échelle mais
ce que j'ai connu un Bosnie de voir les
familles qui fuyaient les villages en
feu avec tout sur leurs épaules
de quelques dizaines de milliers
quelques centaines de milliers mais on
parle de millions de gens qui ont du
fuir et puis qui ont été déplacés aussi
à l'intérieur de l'Ukraine c'est
un retour
ici les Ukrainiens on va en reparler on
va retourner tout de suite à Ottawa
rejoindre Daniel
vous venez de parler justement au chef
d'état-major le général air
voilà c'est entretenu un peu plus tôt
avec le général Wayne et qui était ici
pour la première cérémonie normale
depuis la fin de la période de la fin
des restrictions sanitaires imposées par
la par la pandémie je lui ai demandé
pourquoi c'est important d'être ici
aujourd'hui voici ce qui ne me répond
[Musique]
comment comment vont les forces comment
se portent les forces vous allez
traverser une période quand même un peu
tumultueuse au cours des dernières
années et des scandales à l'interne un
peu
comment se porte les forces
nous avons beaucoup de filles beaucoup
de filles pour augmenter nos effectifs
mais dans les dans le monde notre
système global et sous menace nous
devons affronter le menaces à protéger
notre prospère était nationale
c'est une pour nous en canal au Canada
le menace c'est plus en plus important
de réaliser général whene merci beaucoup
un plagiaire
voilà merci Daniel générale donc qui
parlait de l'importance de d'être
présent de se rappeler en cette Journée
du souvenir dans quelques minutes on
attend l'arrivée des représentants du
gouvernement de la gouverneur général
mairie Simon pour le côté plus
protocolaire de cette cérémonie et
également la mer nationale de la croix
d'argent vous savez c'est une mer qui
représente toutes celles qui ont perdu
un fils ou une fille au service du
Canada cette année il s'agit de Madame
kendigriff elle vient de l'Alberta elle
sera accompagnée de son époux Greg son
fils le caporal-chef barring greffe a
été tué en octobre 2011 en fait c'est le
dernier membre des Forces armées
canadiennes qui a perdu la vie en
Afghanistan alors c'est elle tout à
l'heure qui ira déposé une couronne sur
le monument après la cérémonie au nom de
toutes les mers qui ont perdu un enfant
au service de la nation c'est bien sûr
un grand honneur mais qui porte avec lui
des souvenirs très douloureux mat vous
voyez nous la présente
des photos de son Facebook
mais c'est une prise après la naissance
d'un de ces petits-enfants et sa
préférée des souvenirs déjà précieux
devenus inestimables depuis la mort de
barringf le 29 octobre 2011 en
Afghanistan
11 ans plus tard sa mère est toujours
sous le choc et peine à croire que son
fils vraiment intitulé le caporal-chef
barringf on était à son deuxième séjour
en Afghanistan le parachutisme membre de
l'infanterie participait à la formation
des soldats afgans quand l'autobus
blindé de l'OTAN au bord duquel il se
trouvait a été la cible d'un kamikaze
une mission qui devait être moins
dangereuse que sa première
choisit jeune la carrière du militaire
après un passage chez les cadets une
surprise pour sa famille ou personne
avant lui n'avait fait carrière dans
l'armée
mon fils voulait toujours aider tout le
monde c'est pour ça qu'il avait choisi
une carrière militaire raconte sa mère
en vigueur de 2000m 2014 la mission en
Afghanistan a été la plus longue
opération de combat de l'histoire
militaire canadienne Barringer fait le
158e et dernier soldat canadien mort
dans le pays
en portant la croix d'argent calligray
faut accepter le titre qu'elle portera
pendant un an pour tous les autres morts
durant cette longue opération
par la mort de son fils est immense mais
les souvenirs eux ne se limitent pas aux
photos dans le cimetière près de chez
elle ou
reporté à sa mémoire un banc pour tout
si son nom sur le terrain de son
ancienne école secondaire
les gens doivent être conscients du
sacrifice de mon fils croix madame
greffe de barren et des autres soldats
morts en devoir les souvenirs sont
gardés précieusement en portant la croix
d'argent Candy Griever maintenant les
partager avec tous les Canadiens
donc la mère à la croix d'argent c'est
une tradition très canadienne qui
n'existe pas partout absolument
dix mille femmes qui se sont vues
accorder cette honneur là donc c'est un
patrimoine c'est un héritage important
au pays quand on pense à 90 000
personnes qui ont reçu cet honneur là et
je pense que c'est un symbole qui évolue
aussi parce qu'on pense notamment à des
rois des marques qui ont été octroyés à
des des soldats différents on pense même
à ceux qui ont comme ils se suicide
après l'Afghanistan ce qui était pas le
cas au départ c'était souvent des gens
qui avaient combattu donc les portes
s'ouvrent à une plus grande
reconnaissance des sacrifices consentis
par les mers il y a aussi une qui est
extraordinaire Marie évidemment
en 2006 pour Nicolas Godard qui est en
première femme qui vous combat en
Afghanistan aussi je pense qu'on on a
des petits problèmes avec votre micro on
va essayer de régler ça pendant qu'on
voit ces images toujours
impressionnantes de ces soldats c'est
très solennel c'est très protocolaire et
on sent une certaine émotion parce que
c'est vrai que ça fait deux ans donc il
y a pas eu de cérémonies comme ça ou les
gens pouvaient se rassembler se réunir
et on attend maintenant l'arrivée du
dignitaires pour commencer la partie
plus officielle de cette cérémonie la
gouverneur général bien sûr et le
ministre des Anciens Combattants
le Premier ministre Justin Trudeau qui
lui était on voit le les premiers
cortèges arrivés donc le premier
ministre Justin Trudeau lui qui n'est
pas ici il est il est en route vers
plusieurs grands sommets en Asie mais il
a participé à une cérémonie du souvenir
il y a deux jours à Gaetan le nouveau
bruit
et on va voir quelques images
et plutôt aujourd'hui alors qu'il était
en route en avion il s'est arrêté
incorridge et on l'a aussi vu avec le
personnel militaire qui l'accompagne
notamment
pour souligner cette journée du souvenir
alors voilà l'arrivée ministre des
Anciens Combattants il y aura aussi Greg
Pieters qui est huissier du bâton noir
et lui remplace le président du Sénat ce
sont eux donc ils vont représenter le
gouvernement canadien et voilà ils sont
accompagnés de Sophie Grégoire Trudeau
et de son fils Xavier qui est âgé de 15
ans
le Premier ministre donc se trouve va
participer d'abord à un sommet de
l'Association des nations de l'Asie du
Sud-Est c'est au Cambodge donc il
devrait arriver à Phnom Penh souper
ensuite il ira Bali pour le G20 et
ensuite un sommet de l'APEC à Bangkok et
puis à toute fin de son voyage un sommet
de la Francophonie en Tunisie
alors c'est dignitaire qui se dirige
maintenant vers le monument et on attend
la gouverneur général mairie Simons
ainsi que cette mère à la croix d'argent
donc dont on a parlé tout à l'heure on
disait ça c'est un d'une tradition très
canadienne
ça manque l'autre côté du service on
parle des combattants qui sont décédés
qui sont handicapés mais souvent on
oublie que ces douleurs-là sont
partagées aussi par leur famille et je
pense que c'est cette dame là c'est ce
qu'elle représente parce qu'il faut le
réaliser c'est ce dos là et avait des
familles et puis les familles ont subi
les pas tout simple pratique les mêmes
conséquences que que ces gens-là
l'éloignement l'inquiétude de savoir
s'ils allaient revenir le fait d'y voir
revenir blessé physiquement ou
psychologiquement donc ils ont vécu
aussi ce stress là d'une façon
différente mais il faut pas les oublier
parce que aujourd'hui c'est eux qui
éventuellement s'occupe de ces gens-là
quand c'est possible on parle d'épouse
on parle de mère on parle de frère de ça
donc c'est important que d'avoir aux
côtés des vétérans cette dame-là qui
finalement représente toutes ces
familles là d'ailleurs qui représente
donc toutes ces mers et toutes ces
toutes ces familles comme vous dites
qu'il y avait qui ont perdu des proches
perdus un fils une fille
et qui vive avec ce souvenir douloureux
tous les jours
beaucoup de gens quand même qui sont
réunis là pour
rendre hommage à ses anciens et
combattants alors la mère de la croix
d'argent qui est
escorté jusqu'au monument où elle va
prendre place pour assister à cette
cérémonie très protocolaire on disait
Instagram pour elle
et pour toutes les familles en fait
d'être représentées là c'est un beau
geste en fait que le Canada a posé on
vous sent assez ému
effectivement il faut savoir aussi
qu'elle va être cette dame là tout au
cours tout au long de l'année qui va
éventuellement être en mesure aussi de
participer à d'autres cérémonies d'être
en contact avec d'autres familles aussi
et puis c'est ce qu'elle représente la
douleur l'espoir aussi de toutes ces
familles là qui doit vivre avec un deuil
mesdames et messieurs son excellence la
très honorable merci la gouverneur
général Mel Simon qui arrive allez bien
sûr commandant en chef des forces
américaines elle arrive avec son époux
donc monsieur Freezer
dans une dizaine de minutes ce sera le
moment très émouvant de cette cérémonie
deux minutes de silence donc à 11 heures
pour souligner l'armistice
[Musique]
la fin de la Première Guerre mondiale la
fin de la première guerre mondiale
et à l'époque on croyait que ce serait
la dernière aussi c'est ce qu'on disait
c'est ce qu'on dit après chaque chaque
grande guerre plus jamais plus jamais ça
malheureusement on se retrouve dans une
situation où on les images
s'entrecroisent quand on voit ses villes
ukrainiennes détruites on peut penser à
ce qui s'est passé aussi en Tchétchénie
ou en Syrie mais bien sûr bien avant
pendant la première et la deuxième
guerre mondiale
la gouverneur général donc qui porte
l'uniforme des Forces armées canadiennes
c'est ça
le président de la Légion elle va
prendre place et on va lui faire d'abord
le garde-à-vous et ensuite
le salut général salut vice royal
[Musique]
alors c'est bien sûr le la fin de la
première guerre mondiale qu'on souligne
le 11 novembre mais aussi tous les
autres conflits les soldats qui sont
tombés dans tous les autres conflits pas
seulement pas seulement la première
guerre mais ça a été une guerre qui a
été très sanglante pour le Canada oui
complètement c'est plus de 68000 morts
c'est l'intervention la plus grande pour
le Canada les chiffres de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale sont pas aussi grands on
voulait justement éviter de subir autant
de pertes que dans la première guerre
mondiale pour une nation qui était d'une
toute petite taille à l'époque aussi qui
était encore un Dominion donc
c'est les traditions sont en cries dans
la première guerre mondiale mais
elles ont évolué justement pour inclure
d'autres conflits pour être de plus en
plus inclusif finalement on voit la
liberté canadienne dans cette première
guerre
66655 soldats
173.000 blessés pour un total de 650 000
soldats qui ont participé à ce conflit
évidemment il y a très peu de témoins
directs qui restent de ce moment-là il y
en a maintenant de la de la deuxième
guerre mondiale qui sont encore là
certains qui sont très âgés aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs on aura un peu plus tard un
extrait d'un
ancien combattant un monsieur Lalande 99
ans extrêmement touchant qui est encore
tous ces moyens c'est extraordinaires de
le voir donc on vous présentera ça un
peu plus tard tout à l'heure après cette
cérémonie
la majorité des vétérans ils ont en
moyenne aujourd'hui 59 ans ceux de la
deuxième guerre 97 ans alors comment
est-ce que vous faites pour intéresser
parce que vous en occupez au centre
juniaux comment vous vous intéressez les
jeunes à ce devoir de mémoire mais je
pense que en utilisant des outils
adaptés des outils pédagogiques faits
pour eux il y a vraiment moyen de les
intéresser nous on a la chance d'avoir
un visiteur sur cinq qui est de moins de
18 ans au centre donc ça montre que
vraiment un intérêt une curiosité pour
les choses qui sont soi-disant du passé
il y a énormément d'intérêts et puis on
le voit avec les enseignants avec qui on
collabore les artistes les associations
il y a une réelle demande de s'impliquer
de pouvoir faire de pouvoir inclure
aussi la jeunesse dans des cérémonies
dans des activités dans des programmes
donc comment les intéresser je crois que
c'est en laissant parler de l'humain
finalement on les sent parler les
témoignages de racontant voilà
exactement
bien sûr le centre Juneau c'est c'est
la plage de Juno c'est là où le
débarquement de Normandie a commencé
pour la libération de la France donc
c'est ça qui est commémoré pendant que
toutes les dignitaires se préparent à
prendre place pour cette cérémonie
vous-même vous avez des étudiants à
l'université vous leur en parler aussi
de
devoir de mémoire il s'exercent aussi
d'une minute de silence au moins et puis
il faut un temps aussi de leur parler
des effets d'armes comme aujourd'hui
entre autres si j'étais à l'université
mais on parlerait du 9e anniversaire
de Dieppe de cette opération-là pour moi
c'est important mais aussi le furialiser
que
le fait de vendre le coquelicot le fait
de d'être présent à divers endroits dans
ma localité je m'aperçois que les jeunes
sont très intéressés posent des
questions par le des médailles qu'est-ce
que vous avez fait et puis je trouve
aussi qu'ils sont très généreux
ça aussi c'est important pour moi de
voir ce qui donne des sous OK et puis
évidemment ça permet d'aider les
enseignants
très important et exactement mais aussi
c'est le fait comme leur dit de le
porter c'est pas juste question de
donner mais c'est fait de faire partie
de cette solidarité là de gens qui se
rappellent et puis c'est ce que le
coquelicot veut tout simplement dire je
veux dire c'est c'est un hommage de la
Première Guerre mondiale
du grand poète qui était monsieur
donc pour moi c'est c'est ça qui est
important de faire partie de ce groupe
d'humain là qui se rappelle et puis qui
garde le souvenir vivant c'est ça qui
est important
alors cette cérémonie elle est sur le
point de commencer il y aura deux
minutes de silence sur le coup de 11
heures des anciens combattants viendront
lire l'acte du souvenir il y aura aussi
un défilé aérien alors on va regarder
cette cérémonie ensemble et on va se
retrouver tout de suite après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ne vieilliront pas comme nous qui
leur avons survécu
il ne connaîtront jamais le traçage ni
le poids des années
[Musique]
avec respect je vous invite à un moment
de réflexion
de toutes les générations qui ont
consenti à servir notre pays et à ceux
et celles qui poursuivent encore cette
mission chaque sacrifice chaque
sacrifice est inscrit dans le ciment qui
façonne la paix de notre pays et
ainsi ne peut être oublié par conséquent
alors que le Canada se rassemblent
aujourd'hui puis son nom à être inspirés
et remplis d'admiration pour ceux et
celles qui ont tant donné
cette année en particulier nous faisons
mémoire du 80e anniversaire du raid de
Dieppe
et de l'opération jubilé et nous faisons
mémoire du service de ceux et celles
dont le service
a finalement été reconnu par tout le
monde le deuxième bataillon de
contractions
de nos anciens combattants et de nos
militaires toujours en service qui
souffre de blessures physiques ou
psychologiques
plus style trouver la guérison et la
paix
oui
[Musique]
qui ont soutenu et qui ont souffert avec
les militaires elles sont une source de
force et de sollicitude
indispensables et infiniment précieuse
nous demandons la force pour les
dirigeants du monde et pour les
dirigeants de notre pays pour notre
souverain Charles II le roi du Canada
qui continue de vivre le deuil de sa
mère reine Élisabeth II
pour la gouverneur général
le Premier ministre
et le chef de l'état-major
puisse-t-il nous guider avec sagesse
en temps de guerre et de paix
dans un monde plein de tension et
d'instabilité ou la guerre continue de
faire rage en Ukraine nous nous
réunissons pour
infirmir notre détermination pour
éliminer les barrières des divisions
dans un esprit de réconciliation
tu as rien à raconter un coin nous
recherchons le dialogue entre nous à
tous les niveaux dans la sphère sociale
politique et religieuse
pour que en pratiquant ce dialogue nous
puissions arriver à une paix durable
puissions nous tous et toutes nous
efforcer de poursuivre nos efforts pour
construire un monde meilleur
n'oublions pas
Mesdames et Messieurs le cortège vice
Royal déposera maintenant leur couronne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la mer à la croix d'argent qui
vient de déposer une couronne au nom de
toutes les mers du Canada un peu plus
tôt on l'a vu la gouverneur général
faire de même déposer une couronne
pendant qu'on entend le poème au chant
d'honneur ce fameux poème du
lieutenant-colonel John McCrae où il
fait mention des coquelicots qui
poussaient sur les champs de bataille
d'Europe durant la Première Guerre
mondiale et qui donc à l'origine de
cette grande campagne du coquelicot
comme symbole du jour du Souvenir ça
date de 1921 alors les dignitaires vont
maintenant alors chacun leur tour
déposer ses couronnes tout de suite on
va aller rejoindre Daniel Thibault qui
était sur place donc plusieurs sont
contents de pouvoir participer aux
personnes à cette cérémonie Daniel pour
la première fois depuis le début de la
pandémie
voilà depuis 2 ans maintenant c'est
la première cérémonie depuis le début de
la pandémie où on reprend certains sens
une normalité d'ailleurs vous l'avez
probablement vu sur les images il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui se sont
déplacés aujourd'hui de chaque côté de
la place de la Confédération plusieurs
rangées de personnes qui sont là c'est
un gros changement par rapport aux
années dernière
on évitait ce genre de rassemblement
public cérémonie très très touchante
retour à la normale présence de vétérans
évidemment vous les avez vu ils sont
devant
ces moments solennel pour eux c'est
maman touchant c'est des gens qui qui
viennent ici pour qui s'importent d'être
ici
un moment qui recense des souvenirs
difficiles qui rappellent des compagnons
qu'ils ont perdu au combat et il y a les
vétérans qui sont là il y a les autres
qui sont dans la foule aussi qui sont
déplacés sont venus ici pour rendre
hommage à des compagnons à des frères
d'armes j'ai l'occasion d'en rencontrer
un peu plus tôt ce matin qui est arrivé
de Québec avec sa conjointe sa nouvelle
conjointe qui vient ici pour la première
fois et c'est important pour eux parce
que lui voulait lui montrer pourquoi
c'est important pour lui il a été Ottawa
pendant 28 ans il a été dans les forces
pendant 36 ans elle c'est ça première
visite ici je me suis entretenu avec un
peu plus tôt voici ce que ça donne
[Musique]
assez spécial je suis un ancien
combattant
et puis c'est la première fois que vous
venez ici en personne c'est ça
la cérémonie oui c'est la première fois
qu'on se dit faut souvenir d'un faut
jamais jamais les oublier parce que en
fait la sacrifice pierre note qui en
fait des sacrifices ils sont venus
blessés puis qui continuent de faire des
sacrifices parce que leur vie est
affecté pour toujours
[Musique]
les élus de monsieur qui avait un
message à la fin de notre conversation à
qui j'ai demandé pourquoi c'est
important pour les jeunes la nouvelle
génération il y a des jeunes pour qui
même l'Afghanistan c'est encore c'est
quelque chose de bien plus concret
pourquoi c'est important pour eux de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
il disait c'est un moment c'est un petit
moment dans l'année c'est important pour
eux de comprendre que ce petit moment là
il est important pour ce que ça veut
dire les gens sont encore en vie pour se
souvenir de ce qui a été fait pour faire
en sorte que eux ces enfants-là vivent
dans un pays comme le Canada libre
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs monsieur ricin je
vais présenter aujourd'hui des groupes
d'étudiants un peu plus tard cet
après-midi justement pour transmettre un
spécial je la transmettre ce souvenir ça
fait partie du devoir du devoir de
souvenirs
ce devoir de mémoire si important merci
Daniel
ouais c'est touchant de voir cette
ancien combattant pour qui c'est
tellement important d'être là et de
prendre ce moment évidemment on peut
penser à ces anciens combattants tous
les jours de l'année mais finalement il
y a 7 journées qui leur est consacré on
parlait de l'Afghanistan c'est pas si
loin pourtant le Canada a été a été là
pendant de nombreuses années en poste et
mais le temps passe les années passent
donc il faut réexpliquer le Canada était
là de 2001 à 2014 il y a 140000 soldats
qui ont participé à la mission 158
soldats hommes et femmes évidemment qui
ont perdu la vie
puis aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec une
situation où très précaire où les
talibans sont venus au pouvoir vous
comment vous vous ressentez tout ça moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est malheureux
c'est malheureux les progrès qu'on avait
fait et puis de voir que graduellement
tous les jours on apprend que les femmes
perdent de plus en plus
est-ce que nos 158 militaires et les
civils les journalistes sont laissés en
arrière pour pratiquement rien et puis
il s'agit de voir aussi qu'il y a encore
tellement de d'interprètes qui doivent
se cacher avec leur famille de peur
d'être éventuellement subir les
représailles des talibans qui attendent
d'être d'avoir un avion d'avoir quelque
chose pour être patriot-canada comme le
Canada c'est un langage
et pourtant il y a très peu qui sont qui
ont pu revenir ici c'est malheureux
c'est malheureux ayant connu quelque
chose du genre on devient on vit
pratiquement
quotidiennement avec ces interprètes là
et ils pensent au travers des mêmes
dangers je veux dire que les militaires
parce qu'ils doivent être au front avec
eux vous permettent de vos yeux et vos
oreilles sur le terrain il vous permet
de traduire il vous explique aussi
des dangers pour leur famille parce que
ces gens-là c'est pas juste des jeunes
célibataires c'est des gens qui
ont des épouses ont une famille donc qui
mettaient leur vie tous les jours en
danger parce qu'il croyait effectivement
qu'on ferait en mesure de pouvoir
changer et puis de voir que finalement
on est en train de pour toutes les
pratiques de revenir à ce que c'était
avant
2000 c'est malheureux c'est un échec
cuise
de cet échec pour le Canada on le voit
assez clairement pour la communauté
internationale aussi il faut juste pour
le Canada c'est l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale qui pour toute
sympathique qui a décidé de
je parlais des interprètes surtout parce
que quand même des pays qui en ont fait
peut-être un peu plus que le Canada
c'est pas c'est pas parfait toute
considération le Canada c'est lui que
subit le pourcentage le plus élevé de
pertes donc je pense que ça signifie
quelque chose
du moins pour moi ça veut dire beaucoup
c'est que le Canada oui on n'est pas
gros mais lorsqu'on Yvon il va ils on
donne tout ce qu'on peut donner puis
dans les situations qui sont extrêmement
dangereuses alors on voit encore des
anciens combattants qui viennent porter
des couronnes et un peu plus tard
d'ailleurs les gens vont laisser leur
coquelicots une fois que ce sera terminé
sur l'attente du soldat inconnu ça aussi
c'est devenu au fil des ans une autre
tradition
de laisser ses souvenirs
mais je pense qu'il faut se rappeler
aussi que le jour de souvenirs c'est
c'est pour se souvenir du sacrifice
d'une nation parce que finalement c'est
toute la nation qui contribué ces
conflits donc c'est quelque chose qui
s'ajoute aussi très important pour le
Canada de garder ses souvenirs non
vivants oui pour ceux qui sont plus avec
nous mais pour se rappeler que c'est un
sacrifice une nation et puis Dieu sait
que des gens qui ont souffert de ces
guerres
vous travaillez en France au Centre Juno
donc est-ce que on commémore cette
journée du 11 novembre différemment en
Europe en France notamment mais c'est
sûr que c'est plus relié au 11 novembre
de la Première Guerre mondiale laisser
moins inclusif comme on le voit au
Canada des autres conflits mondiaux donc
il y a plusieurs autres dates qui
commémorent des moments importants
notamment avec l'histoire de la
Résistance en France il y a des dates
importantes l'appel de Charles de Gaulle
par exemple en juin 1940 il y a toutes
sortes de moments qui sont célébrés mais
c'est vrai que le 11 novembre en France
est vraiment associé uniquement à la
Première Guerre mondiale et c'est le
devoir de mémoire est plus important ou
plus ancré dans les dans
les gens mais je dirais qu'ils sont un
peu moins familiers avec le coquelicot
et tout toutes les symboles qui viennent
avec ça toute la symbolique aussi
déposer son coquelicot au monument du
soldat inconnu ils ont pas tous ces
gestes là que nous on a développé au fil
des années mais je pense que comme la
destruction s'est produite partout en
Europe les souvenirs sont quand même
encore vivants de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale beaucoup plus que au Canada
c'est sûr il l'ont vécu dans leur cher
et dans leur village dans leur ville
donc il y a encore la reconstruction a
mis des années en France et en Europe
jusque dans les années 70 donc il y a
plein de générations qui l'ont encore
dans leur souvenir propre
actuel on peut penser que l'Ukraine ça
va être la même chose ça va prendre des
années pour reconstruire donc on a quand
même la chance ici d'avoir été épargné
par ses grands conflits mais je regarde
ces un combattant il y a d'énormes défis
faut face à d'énormes défis quand ils
reviennent ici il y avait toutes sortes
de retards il y avait toutes sortes de
difficultés faisaient face à toutes
sortes de difficultés est-ce que ça
est-ce que le sort de nos anciens
combattants s'améliore ou pas je crois
que le sens améliore c'est sûr qu'il y a
encore d'énormes progrès à faire moi
j'ai souvent que
ayant est un ancien combattant et un
besoin de ses services là ce qui est
plus difficile c'est c'est pas avoir de
personnes d'attester à des anciens
combattants chaque fois que vous appelez
c'est toujours quelqu'un qui doit
prendre connaissance de votre dossier et
puis pour certains c'est très difficile
de
continuellement d'avoir appelé ça et
puis on va aussi qu'il y a énormément de
retards qui sont tout simplement
inappropriés on parle du côté des femmes
du côté des des hommes francophones que
c'est ça peut aller jusqu'à un an avant
que votre dossier soit ouvert ou soit
le processus soit réellement mis en
marche alors que le gouvernement c'était
tout même engagé cette semaine des
demandes d'invalidité et très long et
plus long pour les francophones pour les
francophones et puis plus long aussi
pour les femmes francophones on parle
jusqu'à une heure c'est alors que ça
devrait être cette semaine
probablement par ces services sont pas
là peut-être parce que il y a pas assez
de personnes pour s'occuper de tous ces
gens-là c'est ça qui est malheureux et
puis souvent aussi je me compare à
d'autres personnes moi je suis en mesure
de pouvoir facilement les harceler de
continuer de rappeler mais il y en a
plusieurs qui ont pas ce courage là et
puis lorsqu'on considère le taux de
suicide chez entre autres chez des
anciens combattants de la guerre
d'Afghanistan on peut on peut facilement
comprendre que ça doit être pénible pour
ces gens-là de continuellement d'avoir
à cogner aux portes mais je vous dis il
y a eu des progrès de fait mais il y a
encore beaucoup de progrès à faire et
puis c'est quelque chose qui selon moi
je veux dire on devrait pas oublier
autant que c'est important
se souvenir du 11 novembre on devrait
considérer que chacun individu qui fait
appel qui demande de l'aide on devrait
en mesure de pouvoir leur donner compte
tenu du fait qu'ils étaient au service
du pays parce qu'on oublie peut-être à
quel point ça peut être difficile pour
des soldats qui sont en mission qui sont
qui vont combattre à l'extérieur et qui
reviennent après au pays pour se
réintégrer dans la vie civile oui ben il
faut savoir que maintenant les chiffres
sont beaucoup moins aussi on pense
peut-être en 1945 les vétérans
représentaient 9% de la population donc
il y avait un poids démographique qui
faisait en sorte que il y avait une
panoplie de programme qui était mis en
place pour leur intégration à la vie
civile maintenant le poids démographique
des vétérans est beaucoup moins donc
c'est sûr que qu'il y a moins de choses
en place actuellement pour les vétérans
qu'il y en a eu après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale par exemple il faut tout de
même soulever que souligner le fait que
énormément d'efforts pour du côté des
militaires qui prennent leur retraite il
y a énormément d'efforts de fait pour
mieux les intégrer pour mieux les outils
à faire face à la vie civile et puis
éventuellement pour les diriger vers les
bons services meilleur demeure pour moi
qui c'est la période d'attente pour une
première demande et beaucoup trop longue
et à quel point c'est c'est difficile de
réintégrer la vie civile pour un soldat
parce que c'est une vie complètement
différente
quand on est en mission comme je dis
souvent c'est le nous OK lorsque vous
êtes militaire c'est le nous qui prend
toute la place vous ne vivez que pour le
nous parce que c'est le nous qui va vous
garder en vie c'est nous qui va vous
permettre de faire face à demain alors
que lorsque vous venez vous civil il
faut réapprendre à mettre de l'avant le
mois le jeu et puis c'est pas toujours
évident de mettre le jeu en avant
lorsque vous avez vous pratiquement
dicté lorsque vous êtes en opération
quand vous coucher quand manger c'est
totalement pris en charge totalement
pris en charge et puis souvent c'est un
peu le problème quand même des anciens
combattants qui ont besoin d'aide c'est
que on est tellement habitué que
lorsqu'on est militaire que tout est là
pour nous on nous prend par la main pour
nous administrer alors que le
soudainement vous devez vous administrer
donc le jeu doit reprendre la place mais
ça fait 20 ans 30 ans que c'est nous qui
s'occupe du jeu c'est un peu comme une
famille et puis du jour au lendemain une
famille éclatée et puis là vous vous
retrouvez seul c'est pas évident et ça
peut avoir des impact
alors on attend on va reprendre cette
cérémonie puisque ce sera bientôt
l'heure de la bénédiction en écotera ça
mais c'est ce retour à la vie civile qui
représente de grands défis oui
absolument je pense que chaque
génération devait terrain
ces difficultés à surmonter c'est
l'oubli c'est l'indifférence qui est
aussi je pense affectent énormément
cette solitude que vous décrivez si bien
moi c'est aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
gens qui sont là pour justement rendre
hommage un souci anciens combattants on
va écouter un instant
c'est plus important
dans quel but
du 11e
nous 30 ans de répondre à ses questions
qu'avons-nous perdu
la réponse est aussi simple que
douloureuse les meilleurs les plus
courageux les plus braves de nos fils de
nos frères de nos filles de nos soeurs
de nos pères de nos mères ces âmes
héroïques se sont tenus debout en
sacrifié leur vie leur corps leur esprit
tout ce qu'ils étaient
avons perdu
nous savons c'est qui a été sacrifié
mais dans quel but
le but essentiellement c'est la liberté
la liberté un idéal pour lequel on se
bat encore aujourd'hui que des hommes et
des femmes courageux dans différentes
régions du monde continuent de défendre
une chose qu'on ne peut pas tenir pour
acquise pour citer un ancien militaire
c'est le soldat et pas le ministre qui
nous a donné la liberté de religion
c'est le soldat et non le poète qui nous
a donné la liberté de parole c'est le
soldat et non les organisateurs sont des
campus qui nous ont conquis la liberté
de manifester c'est le soldat qui salue
le drapeau qui sert le drapeau et dont
le cercueil est enveloppé dans le
drapeau qui permet aux protestataire de
brûler le drapeau nous vivons dans un
pays où nous avons la possibilité de
tenir pour acquis cette idéal important
parce que ceux qui ont compris que la
vie sans liberté méritait qu'il donne
leur vie pour des personnes même qu'ils
ne connaissaient pas car cette liberté
n'a pas de prix aujourd'hui
en ce jour du Souvenir
nous disons merci et tous les jours nous
devrons dire merci encore et encore
car c'est en disant merci que nous
reconnaissons notre responsabilité
nationale et notre engagement à tenir
ses engagements
en 1917 glissolda Canadiens sont allés
capturer la pointe de Vimy comme lundi
le Premier ministre tout doux il venait
d'un océan à l'autre francophone
anglophone néo-Canadiens des Canadiens
noirs et des autochtones et ils ont
battus pendant quatre jours pour
remporter cette victoire décisive comme
vétérans nous respectons les albertin
les niveaux écossais qui ont donné leur
vie l'histoire de cette bataille et
l'histoire de chacune et chacun de nous
nos chers soldats et leurs familles sont
en première ligne mais chacune et chacun
de nous nous devons faire notre part car
nous sommes là dedans ensemble nous
faisons nous partageons la
responsabilité de préserver l'idéal
sacré de la liberté et
en nous concent sur cet engagement en
saluant l'engagement de ces soldats de
leur famille nous ne contendons pas de
dire merci et de soutenir les anciens
combattants et leurs familles mais en
agissant en donnant notre temps notre
action et nous ressources il y a
tellement de façon de le faire tellement
d'organismes qui nous permettent de
vivre cet engagement cet engagement
sacré à soutenir la santé physique et
mentale de nos anciens combattants et de
leurs familles
alors qu'ils reviennent du front c'est
notre façon de montrer notre gratitude
et d'exprimer clairement que comme
Canadian et canadien nous sommes unis
nous sommes solidaires des femmes et des
hommes courageux des Forces canadiennes
qui continuent de
nous indiquer la voie
la façon dont vous avez donné votre vie
pour chacune et chacun de nous c'est ce
qui nous permet de vivre et de respirer
librement
et c'est pourquoi nous nous engageons
envers vous et vos familles que Dieu
vous préserve d'esprit de corps
maintenant et à jamais AMEN
[Applaudissements]
Mesdames et Messieurs que Dieu protège
le roi avec le cœur des enfants de te
voir
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette cérémonie
officielle vous venez de voir cette
couronne en hommage à Sa Majesté la
reine Elizabeth II c'est une gerbe de
fleurs donc toute spéciale pour
en honneur en hommage à la reine qui est
décédée un peu plus tôt évidemment le
lien entre la royauté et les soldats
canadiens il est toujours présent donc
cette couronne a été mise en place dès
le début de la cérémonie donc ça fait
partie des grands anniversaires qui ont
été soulignés cette année en plus
évidemment de l'anniversaire du raid de
Dieppe ça fait 80 ans cette année
c'était au mois d'août 1942 donc une
cérémonie qui s'achève qu'est-ce que
vous retenez surtout moi c'est la
présence de la jeunesse dans la foule
une certaine mixité aussi dans la foule
je pense que
l'aspect des Premières nations aussi le
fait que l'acte du souvenir soit lui en
est nous de la part d'un ranger ce
Canadien c'est vraiment des symboles
super importants qui font qu'on voit que
les cérémonies évoluent aussi avec le
temps oui exactement on dit que c'est
très protocolaire mais en fait il y a
toujours quand même une petite évolution
à chaque année beaucoup plus éclusif
parce que c'est là avec nous aussi lors
des derniers conflits on les a souvent
oublié il y a eu des héros parmi ces
gens là donc pour moi ça signifie qu'on
les on leur redonne ce qu'ils auraient
dû toujours avoir
pour représenter je veux dire leur
nation qu'ils ont combattu côte à côte
avec nous moi je trouve que c'est
fantastique et puis de voir aussi que on
parle de jeunesse mais on parle aussi au
niveau des vétérans c'est des jeunes
vétérans donc c'est aussi c'est
important de garder des souvenirs c'est
sûr que ça peut être pas la même
importance que le premier puis le
deuxième conflit mondial mais tout de
même j'étais dans un environnement de
guerre ils ont plusieurs ont perdu la
vie donc pour moi ça aussi c'est
significatif que il faut garder le
souvenir vivant mais aussi il faut
s'occuper de nos jeunes vétérans qui
sont qui sont toujours là et qui sont
encore assez jeunes en fait
effectivement ces années devant le défi
de taille ouais pour la Légion royale
canadienne de s'attirer ces nouveaux
vétérans-là de leur ouvrir leurs portes
pour continuer la grande tradition de la
Légion royale canadienne c'est pas
évident générale donc il salue les mains
il y a des dignitaires des diplomates
d'anciens combattants qui sont réunis et
il y aura dans quelques minutes et bien
sûr ce défiler des anciens combattants
qui va se mettre en place et qui va qui
est un moment toujours important parce
que pour eux c'est vraiment le moment où
on leur rend hommage à eux c'est eux qui
prennent à ce moment-là toute la place
après cette cérémonie plus protocolaire
alors on va évidemment il y avait des
cérémonie à Ottawa c'est la grande
cérémonie nationale mais il y avait des
cérémonies un peu partout à Montréal
aussi une cérémonie jour du Souvenir a
eu lieu à la Place du Canada Daniel
Kadjo c'est un bel hommage les anciens
combattants sont vraiment au cœur de
cette célébration
oui Céline et ici on a assisté un
événement important mais surtout émotif
après des célébrations plus sobles l'an
dernier en raison des mesures sanitaires
on le ressent auprès de la foule
présente ici dont certains qui sont là
pour célébrer leur père disparus je
m'écartais un peu pour que vous puissiez
voir on Vienne procéder au dépôt des
couronnes de fleurs et l'événement a
commencé par un mot de bienvenue de la
camarade Paulette Cook au nom de la
Légion Royal il y a des dignitaires qui
sont présents dans le Premier ministre
François Legault sa femme Isabelle la
mairesse Valérie plante ainsi que le
ministre responsable des relations avec
les Premières nations Yann Lafrenière
peut avoir 11 heures l'hymne national a
été interprétée ici ça a été suivi de la
sonnerie aux morts ça c'était avant le
traditionnel premier coup de canon on a
observé deux minutes de silence avant
une serve de 21 coups de canon et
également il y a un survol d'hélicoptère
voici quelques réactions recueillies un
peu plus tôt
je suis là en mémoire de mon père qui
est parti dans la guerre mondiale était
là sur les tâches de Normandie puis
chaque année est venu ici mais il est
décidé qu'un printemps fait que je viens
avec mon fils pour garder sa mémoire
vraiment pour se souvenir de tout ce qui
ont fait pour nous c'est un moment
d'humilité et de se recentrer sur ce qui
est la cause humaine
libertins qui sont décédés ils ne sont
pas revenus là-bas
j'ai vraiment le choix on se rappelle
des souvenirs ou qu'est-ce qu'on a vécu
qu'est-ce que des bons puis des mauvais
souvenirs puis les bonnes affaires
oui on se souvient et Daniel il y a
d'autres événements qui sont aussi
prévus au cours de la journée
oui le ministre français de la justice
est présentement de passage au Québec il
est assistant un événement à 15h30 au
parc La Fontaine au monument
commémorative franco-canadiens
exceptionnellement aujourd'hui le pont
Champlain c'est la Samuel de Champlain
sera illuminé en rouge à partir du
coucher du soleil jusqu'à 20h pour
souligner le Jour du Souvenir merci
beaucoup Daniel
[Musique]
on retrouve Daniel l'autre Daniel qui
parle de devoir de mémoire puisque
Daniel vous êtes allé au Musée canadien
de la guerre à Ottawa rencontré un
bibliothécaire dans la mission et
d'aider les familles des vétérans à
reconstruire un petit peu leur passé
voilà fouiller le patrimoine militaire
des gens vous avez le musée de la guerre
évidemment donner centrales des
célébrations des commémorations du jour
du Souvenir à Ottawa le musée est ouvert
accessible gratuitement aux gens du
public aujourd'hui il y a une aile du
musée qui est la bibliothèque ou Vincent
Lafon et bibliothécaire et lui cette
semaine va offrir deux ateliers aux gens
qui sont intéressés pour déterminer
comment on peut aller fouiller le passé
militaire d'un proche d'un membre de la
famille
vétéran de la Première Guerre mondiale
de la deuxième guerre mondiale qui a
peut-être pas partagé toute son
expérience alors qu'il est de son vivant
et dont les proches aujourd'hui veulent
en savoir un peu plus sur ce qu'il a
vécu il y a des outils pour ça Vincent
Lafont nous les décrit
la demande typique c'est quelqu'un qui a
un nom puis que peu d'informations parce
que même si c'est des survivants au
conflit les vétérans partagaient pas
nécessairement leur histoire qui était
qui était traumatisante pour certains
d'entre eux donc les gens la famille
veulent savoir ce que leur leurs
ancêtres les membres de la famille ont
fait ils ne savent pas il voudra en
savoir davantage donc c'est vraiment la
porte d'entrée c'est vraiment ça par où
on commence qu'est-ce qu'on a au départ
comme information pour nous permettre
d'en trouver davantage donc les gens
parfois peuvent avoir un objet comme une
casquette ou un insigne de casquette
peuvent avoir une médaille peuvent avoir
des documents textuels qui soient des
des journaux aux intimes ou de la
correspondance des lettres on peut ça
peut être une photo sur laquelle on voit
des gens avec uniforme ça peut être une
pierre tombale ou ça peut être
simplement le nom vous leur donnez quoi
comme outil pour leur permettre d'aller
plus loin on va donner les différents
outils qui sont accessibles en ligne ou
dans différents services de bibliothèque
comme ici musique canadiens de la gare
si on cherche des objets par exemple on
peut aller sur le catalogue
la musique canadien de la guerre où on
va chercher par des mots clés et trouver
des exemples d'objets similaires à ceux
qui possèdent on peut aussi vérifier
dans la bibliothèque si on a des
documents en lien avec l'histoire du
régiment en lien avec des batailles qui
ont été mentionnées dans des documents
qu'ils auraient eus donc ça ça va
permettre aux gens de créer un contexte
plus large par rapport
le patrimoine militaire de la personne
qu'il recherche qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
comme réaction les gens à qui vous
faites découvrir ce détail là parce
qu'il y a des gens qui doivent découvrir
un passé qu'il ne connaissait pas ouais
effectivement ben les gens sont ravis de
voir que on peut à partir d'un an ou
d'un objet connecté et différents
éléments puis découvrir un véhicule
qu'on
ignorait finalement
et Céline vous avez vu les
impressionnantes collection d'ouvrages
militaires de Monsieur Lafont la
pandémie l'a bien servi des gens qui ont
profité de l'occasion pour faire le
ménage de leur bibliothèque ils ont reçu
ma Tizi des centaines de dons de livres
liés à l'histoire militaire canadienne
voilà très intéressant merci Daniel
[Musique]
combattants se poursuivent vous voyez
ils sont applaudis les gens sont émus
aussi on a vu quelques visages presque
au bord des larmes en voyant ses anciens
combattants très fiers
défilé dans les rues du centre-ville
d'Ottawa
c'était intéressant cette cette
initiative au Musée canadien de la
guerre pour que les gens puissent savoir
un peu ce qui s'est passé parce que très
souvent
[Musique]
ces anciens combattants ne racontent pas
vraiment ce qui s'est passé c'est
exactement oui je pense que quand
l'histoire devient familiale devient
personnelle il y a une adhérence qui se
crée c'est à dire que l'histoire de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale n'est plus
anonyme n'est plus généreux et fait
partie de l'histoire d'une famille et ça
ça se transmet comme on a vu la dame qui
est à Montréal avec son enfant les
traditions commencent en bas âge comme
ça et puis je pense que connaissant
encore mieux son patrimoine familial la
Seconde Guerre mondiale on va pouvoir
préserver ce passé là au sein même des
familles
que c'est douloureux donc les les
anciens combattants certains ne
pouvaient pas raconter ce qui s'était
passé une voulait pas le raconter ce qui
ne voulait pas puis probablement qu'il
ne pouvait pas
parce que
faire appel des vieux souvenirs c'est
des blessures moi je sais que ça m'a
pris énormément de temps pour le petit
peu que j'ai connu difficultés en Bosnie
on en a parlé à la famille c'est
vous voyez des choses qui sont
atrocciées il y a pas de mots pour
décrire ce que vous voyez et puis
souvent vous vous êtes un briquet dans
des dans des choses dans des gestes que
vous commettez peut-être que vous auriez
pas du commerce donc il y a toutes
sortes de de
fait qui qui éveillent des blessures qui
qui éventuellement vont provoquer des
cauchemars donc les gens n'aiment pas
tellement d'en parler moi j'ai connu des
des personnes qui ont fout qui ont vécu
la deuxième et puis la guerre de Corée
et puis c'est pas des personnes qui
aimaient même avec les jeunes militaires
parler leur expérience pour eux c'était
derrière eux c'était des blessures qu'il
fallait garder
les cicatrices qu'il faut aller pour
réouvrir parce que c'est un peu seul le
11 novembre
ces cicatrices là et puis
ça ramène paquet d'émotions qui fait pas
nécessaire des choses que vous aimez
revivre et puis peut-être partager parce
que souvent je veux dire ça peut déceler
des signes de faiblesse chez vous donc
moi c'est mon expérience c'est pour
quelque chose que j'ai pendant la après
la Première Guerre mondiale la deuxième
guerre mondiale le syndrome
post-traumatique on en parlait pas
maintenant peut-être que c'est un peu
plus facile pour les plus jeunes
combattants c'est peut-être plus facile
d'en parler mais encore une fois c'est
pour eux pour plusieurs c'est un signe
de faiblesse c'est un signe de faiblesse
c'est un peu comme quelqu'un qui fait
une dépression je veux dire on n'aime
pas parler de ça parce que
même si médicalement c'est démontré que
c'est des symptômes qui sont bien
physiques mais pour plusieurs c'est un
signe de faiblesse et puis
on n'aime pas s'afficher d'accord
justement nous on a pu rencontrer notre
équipe a pu rencontrer un ancien
combattant de 99 ans un monsieur Lalonde
vous allez voir très impressionnant il
nous raconte son histoire on l'écoute
je m'appelle Roland j'ai là onde j'ai 99
ans je suis né le 8 juillet 1923
en Italie
au mois de février quand on est parti on
est allé sur l'Adriatique
qu'on avait et puis pour se rendu à la
fin de la guerre au mois d'avril 1945 on
était obligé de se rendre à Hollande
pour les patrimo les Allemands
après ça on était sur le départ de la
Hollande
la guerre c'est la guerre
la guerre c'est pas très certainement
beau à raconter
[Musique]
la première journée en langue
j'avais un ami là
[Musique]
le major vraiment
beaucoup de
l'Union ou de tiens quand je reviens à
la maison des fois j'ai des problèmes
pour m'endormir mais ça fait partie de
la vie ça ça fait partie du soldat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est important de se souvenir et puis
tu as toujours des chances de rencontrer
des gens que tu as pu connaître mais
c'est presque une obligation c'est une
journée qu'on aimerait oublier mais
qu'on est obligé on est ça fait partie
de notre vie
on fait pas ça pour se faire honorer on
fait ça pour se rappeler nos amis qui
sont morts puis ceux qui ont servi
je me suis bien
au Sénat je vais demander de rester là
je peux pas aller mais je la sais par
cœur
une vieille pas comme nous qui leur
avons sur lui il ne connaîtront jamais
ultra-je ni le poids des années et quand
viendra là que
celle de Laurent nous nous souviendrons
Dieu nous nous souviendrons Dieu
merci Monsieur Lalande pour ce très beau
témoignage merci beaucoup c'est
impressionnant de voir quand même
un ancien combattant la guerre c'est la
guerre il dit puis ses souvenirs
terribles ça fait partie de la vie ça
fait partie du soldat
ça rejoint un peu ce que vous disiez
effectivement rien de plus à ajouter
et puis comme vous avez vu il y a pas
tout dit
en Italie la campagne en Italie a été
très violente pour pour les Canadiens
plusieurs campagnes d'ailleurs on
célèbre le 80ème anniversaire de Dieppe
ça a été très sanglant pour les
Canadiens
et puis c'est encore une opération qui
est beaucoup de polémiques dessus savoir
est-ce que c'était réellement nécessaire
de faire cette opération dans les
conditions dans lesquelles c'est fait il
y a eu beaucoup de blessés 5000
canadiens
et donc pour envoyer un signal aux
Russes qui se battent sur le front est
on dit on va s'impliquer et donc on
débarque à Dieppe de façon
sans doute pas amener l'aviation
allemande pour venir éventuellement
appuyer ou contrecorer les actions et
puis éventuellement affaiblir leur
participation sur le front russe mais
cette opération-là a été mis de l'avant
à l'intérieur de conditions qui ont été
très difficiles et qu'on le veut aussi
je veux dire à peine quelques heures
après le début récupération on a décidé
tout simplement de cancer les cette
opération là avec d'énormes pertes pour
les Canadiens et comment cette
interprété du côté français du côté
canadien mais du côté canadien je pense
que c'est un choc énorme parce que il
était décidé par avant que peu importe
le résultat du règne il serait présenté
comme un événement positif donc après
dans les journaux au Canada on a la
publication des listes des morts et ça
ne colle pas du tout avec ce qui s'est
réellement passé du côté des 5000
Canadiens qui ont participé 916 ont péri
lors du raid 1950 ont été fait
prisonniers par les Allemands donc des
souvenirs douloureux c'est la journée la
plus sanglante pour le Canada durant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et ceux qui vont
vivre la captivité les marches de la
mort par la suite en 1945 vont revenir
avec des séquelles très importantes au
Canada
donc c'est pour vous dire qu'il y a
encore le polémique c'est sûr qu'on a
appris des choses mais des choses qu'on
aurait peut-être pu apprendre à moindre
coût à moindre coût et puis on s'est
servi naturellement c'est ce que les
politiciens c'est ce qui est généraux on
dit à cette époque-là c'est s'il y avait
pas eu Dieppe il aurait fallu qu'il y a
un autre type de
comme Dieppe de façon à pouvoir retirer
les leçons et puis mieux se préparer
entre autres pour le débarquement en
Sicile l'année suivante avec l'opération
au ski et puis éventuellement pour le
débarquement en Normandie en 44
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on semble dire
c'est que les Américains auraient
peut-être voulu initialement débarquer
en 43 mais la catastrophe de Dieppe peut
faire réfléchir que c'était peut-être
mieux de prendre un peu plus de temps
pour mieux se préparer surtout d'avoir
les équipements appropriés pour faire ce
type de débarquement alors c'est pour
tous ces sacrifices quand on est ici
aujourd'hui à parler de ses anciens
combattants vous voyez les gens vont
porter leur coquelicots et là les
anciens combattants
sont visiblement heureux d'être là et de
se retrouver parce que c'est ce dont il
disait un jour du Souvenir monsieur
Lalande disait c'est un jour de
souvenirs c'est pas pour être honoré
c'est vraiment pour se retrouver aussi
se retrouver aussi et puis ça montre le
paradoxe du 11 novembre ne serait plus
ceux qui nous ont quitté dans des
circonstances difficiles et en même
temps de se réjouir de voir des
camarades là qui avec lesquels on a
contribué dans certaines sites de ces
situations là dangereuses et puis de
voir trouver comment ce qui se porte
aujourd'hui
alors notre émission s'achève qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que les Canadiens
retiennent de cette cérémonie mais je
pense que on se tourne vers le futur
maintenant avec nos vétérans modernes
comme on pourrait maintenant les appeler
leur présence signale cette transition
là qui est très importante pour
perpétuer les traditions du passé mais
les adapter aux générations futures pour
surtout l'inclusion de la jeunesse moi
c'est ce que je retiens le plus pendant
qu'on voit le chef
conservateur qui est également
je veux dire que nous système
d'éducation l'étendue du pays puisse
garder cette mémoire cette mémoire le
vivant auprès de nos jeunes de façon à
ce qu'on n'oublie pas merci beaucoup à
vous deux merci de nous avoir suivis on
se laisse sur des moments marquants des
cérémonies d'aujourd'hui merci mesdames
messieurs d'avoir été là au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]